[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHILIP MAIER: Hi, Philip here.
I'm a technical curriculum
developer here at Google.
HARISH BRAHMSANDRA:
And hi from me, Harish.
I'm a lab architect at Google.
On this episode, we'll be
looking at Google Cloud
SDK, a set of tools including
command line tools like GCloud,
bq, and GS [INAUDIBLE] to
help manage your resources
and applications on
Google Cloud Platform.
PHILIP MAIER:
We'll also take you
through a quick demo
of a self-paced lab
where we'll install and
initialize Cloud SDK
and run commands using
GCloud, one of many tools
that come packaged
with Cloud SDK,
and the primary
command line interface
to Google Cloud Platform.
HARISH BRAHMSANDRA: Google Cloud
Console already provides you
with a powerful browser-based
UI to manage the GCP product
and services that
drive your cloud apps.
With the Cloud SDK, you
can manipulate and develop
against your Cloud resources
using command line.
It often provides access to
more options than the console,
but it also makes it possible
for you to script your actions
as well as log and audit them.
PHILIP MAIER: You can
also use Cloud SDK
to access App Engine,
Compute Engine, Cloud Storage
BigQuery, and every other GCP
product from the command line.
And you have the choice to
run these tools interactively
or through automated scripts.
bq is another tool available
in Cloud SDK for BigQuery.
HARISH BRAHMSANDRA: You can
use bq you to create and get
information about resources,
list and update resources, load
and query data, use
external data sources,
export data, and use the
BigQuery data transfer service.
PHILIP MAIER: So
that's a quick taste
of some of the key tools
and functionalities offered
through Cloud SDK.
Looking to install
and initialize
Cloud SDK on the operating
system of your choice?
Click this link for info
on how to get started.
In this lab, you'll learn
to install the Cloud SDK,
initialize it, and
run core GCloud
commands from the command
line on a virtual machine.
The Cloud SDK RPM
packages are supported
for Red Hat Enterprise
Linux 7 and CentOS 7.
HARISH BRAHMSANDRA:
You can check out
the link to start
the quick lab here,
which will take about
30 minutes to complete.
So far in the lab
we have created a VM
with a Red Hat image.
We then SSH to the VM.
We update the Cloud
SDK RPM packages.
We initialize the SDK,
authenticating when prompted.
We can now list accounts
whose credentials
are stored in the VM.
We can list the properties in
our active SDK configuration.
We can view information on
the active SDK configuration.
We can view GCloud
command help, as well as
specific help for a command.
PHILIP MAIER: So that
brings our episode
on Cloud SDK to a close.
We hope you enjoyed it.
We'd love to hear
how you've applied
the tools and
functionalities of Cloud SDK.
So please leave a comment below.
HARISH BRAHMSANDRA:
We hope you have
been able to apply what you
have learned during the series,
using the $300 free
trial credit for GCP.
If you haven't signed
up for the credit yet,
check out this link.
PHILIP MAIER: All of our
additional training resources
are linked below.
Thanks again for watching
and see you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]